as ukrainian soldiers tested their
weapons their president shot down
criticism he's minimizing the threat of
war to his people it's not that we're
acting as if it's not the highest level
of threat we are getting prepared for
the high
threats
but
we understand the reality that we are in
vladimir zelinski says his country is
ready to defend itself should the
kremlin order its soldiers to move into
ukraine and he urged western countries
not to create panic when it comes to the
threat of war russia again said it's not
their country's objective if it depends
on us the russian federation there will
be no war a line zelinski outright
rejects they can do everything they have
a powerful army why do you need drills
to happen specifically here it's not
just russian troops ukraine is
contending with
can you share any information about any
of those sort of physical or cyber
attacks that have been identified or
prevented
so we
have had quite a number of cyber attacks
we have prevented
those and
we did manage to
restore
and
recommission many
websites of our government
institutions
in terms of the physical attacks i think
the strong how strong is our team is
strongest that we can preemptively
prevent knowing that there could be
casualties if we don't
western leaders are working to try to
defuse tensions in a phone call friday
russian president vladimir putin told
francis emmanuel macron that the u.s and
nato had not addressed russia's key
concerns we are working hard
for the best
peaceful political solution but we also
prepared for the worst the canadian
government says it's doing what it can
to support ukraine the defense minister
is expected to travel to the country in
the coming days
jeff
crystal gomezing in kiev ukraine thanks
crystal